here is zach grant you just talked about
a moment ago and you know quietly you
hear about all about houston's offense
but quietly tom they've got the number
one starting staff in terms of era in
the league
and they take the ball deep into games
especially zach grenky when we look at
the scouting report on zach you have to
be ready it all counts for his change-up
it is one of the best the baseball no
extra bass hits that's right no extra
bass hits allowed on it
and he likes to put the ball on the
ground and it's a good thing because
he's like another infielder after he
releases the ball 61 played appearances
that is ripped ashore and caught by
robel garcia off a bounce he'll throw
him out one gone
counts are down but one of the lowest
hard hit rates in the game to bounce at
a third abraham toro with a running
throw to get judged two up and two down
a lot of options
the payoff pitch voigt swings and misses
and zach granky works at one two three
first
so garrett cole makes his return to
houston where he went 35 and 10 over two
seasons and was top five in scion award
voting both years fifth in the american
league with that 291 era so far in 2021
puts this one in the corner pop up right
side of the infield for luke voight
michael brantley and brantley goes after
the first pitch flies it to left
tim lo castro two up and two down
[Applause]
and the pitch there's a wrecking ball
strike guri annuity just threw the bat
away
so
colt has a one two three
now the 1-0
and that's it high in the air out to
left center two is left brantley to his
right straw straw makes the call and the
catch so zac rinke works around a walk
and a single strands a couple of runners
acumen they need
shoots one off the middle backhand
deltuve from short center field jose
altuve
how in the world does he get le castro
with all that speed the transfer
look how quickly he gets rid of this
baseball it's a great play just to get
rid of the ball but i want you to watch
the transfer
he's still moving towards the outfield
as he turns and somehow gets enough on
this baseball
to get one of the fastest runners in the
game real speed
i think the castro might have been
surprised pitch swing on and hit in the
air to deep left that ball is high it is
far it is gone
a judgy and blast what happened is
grinky got a pitch up and paid for it
aaron judge rips a home run to deep left
gives the yankees a one-nothing lead
all rise here comes the judge and 419
feet and that's the way to break an o
for 10-6 strikeouts
the one time he left the pitch up
look at the target
watch the pitch
high high
[Applause]
judge is not going to miss that one
astros is something brewing here first
and second for guriel
[Applause]
fastball right by him at 99 for the
first down of the fourth
hit sharper to second they get it out
there and they turn a double play
four six three lamehiu torres and over
to voight and four shout out innings for
garrett cole
the home run hit on the slide
did he go you bet he did judge retired
yankees down in the fifth halfway home
in houston one-nothing yankees
four no-hit innings from garrett cole
walked a pair last sunday but use a
double play ball to get out of the gym
record in the majors 39 and 20. a little
jam shot into center field for the first
hit of the game for houston
and it comes from abraham toro they made
a really good pitch and the first hit
is
off the barrel
with parachutes in the center field
the one out base hit from toro
he's at second
calls 2-2
bunks on the ground to second for d.j
lemay and the astros unable to take
advantage of their first hit tonight
he was in his mid-20s playing in italy
chase is here strike three on the
change-up from garrett cole everybody's
got everything working now huh
i haven't seen too many of those maybe a
handful tonight but
to the number nine hitter and perfectly
executed
all-star to all-star
in a one-nothing game in the sixth
inning
paul roxen fires 3-2
el tuve smacks it on the ground to
second lamehu throws him out michael
brantley
bouncing ball right side backhand voigt
feeds cole who gets through this
critical inning one two three after six
one nothing new york
this is the third inning of work
for christian javier who's looked good
sticks with it and strikes him out his
fourth k
the results have been very good
agashioka gets on top of it pulls it to
third on a bounce toro with a nice play
too gone
[Music]
that's where he goes and it works
book
[Applause]
[Music]
just the fifth hit of this series for
the astros in 49 at bats kidders in
baseball he's down 02. here and watches
strike three as coal hits 100 for his
8th k
i mean
this is just so impressive we're talking
third time around seventh inning and
you're dotting a fastball with two
strikes at 100 miles per hour
there he goes here it comes
lifted in the ear to left off the end of
the bat for le castro makes the call
and the catch to finish off seven
shutout innings from garrett cole
stanek is just trying to get something
over the plate
to break it open with one swing on 3-0
he does swing away but bounces it gently
into a double play
and the yankees struggles with men on
base continue it stays one nothing to
the bottom of the a
slider to the corner for his ninth
strikeout tonight
a 1-2
and a 10th strikeout for garrett cole
to finish off eight shutout innings
against the astros
you make the call but in this case it
was the home plate umpire look at
garrett cole arguing to stay in and he
will
aaron boone had chapman ready for
alvarez remember alvarez with two home
runs off coal back in may
derek cole goes the distance
99 on the last pitch of the night you
will not see a better pitching
performance
in terms of stuff
in terms of willpower